what was your sort of pixar experience
like was it as magical as everybody sort
of said oh yeah for sure for sure for
sure i mean you know it's it's real you
know the energy is real
pete's real camp's real it's just real
you walk on there
my daughter was like my young girl like
you get to go to pixar
you're actually famous i'm like yeah you
know i do a little something you know
she was like well dad if you're in pixar
film you finally made it
i mean i was so excited to be there you
know when i got this call they're like
you know pete and dana and camp want to
pitch you this idea and i was like okay
but also it's yes
if the idea was that i go to their
houses and clean out their garages the
answer would have been yes
trying to get the character right now
i'm sitting there doing
facial expressions and all then they're
like uh jamie
we don't actually see you we just need
the voices so
but they they walk me through it they
walk me through how to get an animated
voice not just
a voice but when it becomes animated and
so i loved watching that process of
where they take that voice and then they
put it together with these incredible
visuals and incredible ideas and
you got magic kemp and pete were really
nice about me and uh
and sam means and maris gardeno are some
writers that i've worked with for a
while now and there were some sections
where they said yeah you guys want to
you know just want to pitch on some
stuff
um and so that was really and and though
they were also like yes
anything for pixar yes was there any
sort of pressure on you
um this being the first you know
african-american-led pixar movie
not pressure as the uh first
african-american league
because that is something that we
welcome that is something that we want
we want to be a part of that and just to
be honest with you
um and living color was all black
you know keenan ivan writers black
writers that
that's all i ever knew right jamie foxxo
oh it was me
my homie bentley all black that's all we
ever knew we never knew anything
different
i did immediately feel like it was a
beautiful
story and a great idea and i
was thrilled to be a part of a movie
that featured
the first pixar movie to feature a
primarily uh african-american
cast um i was felt very honored to be
asked to be a part of that
um and then when i first also got to see
some of the art too that was like oh
this thing is going to
look so incredible and i always said
it's not just good enough to be black
you got to be great
you know and to see this movie uh get
100 on rotten tomatoes that's when
that's when
that's when you feel great you know
because it's one thing to have this
incredible
uh you know mantle that we can you know
show the light and show kids and
everything
and we want to do that but we also want
to be excellent so uh
it all worked out my family and i got to
go to a little screening
room just the four of us because of the
pandemic and watch it and um
it's you always cry at a pixar movie
because of the story but i think there
are moments where you well up in this
movie
simply from the visuals and the score
i have to ask because everyone's gonna
ask me about this
how is spider-man going what can you
tease
just a little sprinkle a little
something in there
man i tried to say something the other
day man i almost got killed so i don't
want to blow my shot
no okay well we're excited to have you
back in the spider verse if you will
hey man listen man i'm i'm happy all
around
okay